Mais avant toute chose, nous devions trouver un processus de conception
pour utiliser ces pierres aux formes aléatoires.
Nous n'avions jamais fait ça.
De nos jours, cela serait beaucoup plus aisé
car nous irions dans la carrière
munis de nos portables qui intègrent un scanner 3D.
Nous documenterions chaque pierre
avant de créer un modèle numérique, dans un processus bien pensé.
Mais il y a une dizaine d'années, nous devions accepter l'incertitude,
mettre nos bottes, remonter nos manches,
et nous rendre dans la carrière, les mains dans le cambouis.
Nous avons dû également nous transformer en une entreprise de construction
car nous ne trouvions personne pour accepter ces risques avec nous.
Heureusement, nous avons convaincu les équipes dans les carrières
de concevoir quelques prototypes pour résoudre des détails techniques.
Nous nous sommes mis d'accord sur des maquettes.
Notre enthousiasme nous a emportés :
une pierre a mené à une autre jusqu'à réussir à construire
une structure de 18 mètres de long sur 8 mètres de hauteur
en utilisant des matériaux sans forme de la carrière,
soutenue par la gravité uniquement, sans mortier ni ligature.
Après l'avoir construit et testé,
nous l'avons déplacé sur son site final dans le centre de la ville
pour l'assembler au reste de l'édifice.
Ce fut finalement très simple car nous avions isolé les incertitudes
et géré les risques dans un environnement sous contrôle dans la carrière.
Nous avons donc pu achever la construction dans les temps
et dans le budget imparti
en dépit de nos moyens et méthodes peu conventionnels.
J'en ai la chair de poule
quand je regarde ce morceau de paysage industriel
dans la ville,
dans un édifice
et dont les visiteurs et voisins jouissent au quotidien.
Ce bâtiment nous a donné du fil à retordre
et il aurait donc pu rester l'exception.
Toutefois, il a initié un modus operandi
où chaque projet devient une opportunité
de tester les limites d'une discipline
qui, nous le croyons, a un besoin urgent d'être réinventée.
Voici quatre maisons
que nous avons dessinées, construites et habitées.
Quatre manifestes où, à petite échelle,
nous tentons de répondre à de grandes questions.
Nous voulons découvrir les architectures
en détournant l'usage usuel de matériaux banals
et de technologies
telle que le béton de formes différentes, sur les images en haut,
ou de l'acier et de la mousse, sur les images du bas.
Prenons ces poutres préfabriquées en béton.
Vous en avez déjà vu sur les ponts, les autoroutes ou des canaux.
Nous en avons trouvé durant une de nos visites
dans une usine de fabrication de pièces en béton.
Elles ne sont pas particulièrement belles ou appropriées pour une maison.
Mais nous avons décidé de les utiliser pour notre première maison.
Ce fut un moment incroyable pour nous
car nous étions à la fois architectes, bien entendu,
entrepreneurs en construction,
et, pour la première fois, nous devenions notre propre client.
Ici, nous essayons d'imaginer comment poser ces immenses poutres de béton
de 20 tonnes chacune,
et de les empiler progressivement autour d'une cour,
le cœur de la maison.
Grâce à leurs dimensions et à la qualité du matériau,
ces immenses structures non seulement portent la charge
mais elles font davantage.
Ce sont des piscines.
Ce sont les murs qui séparent l'intérieur de l'extérieur.
Ce sont les fenêtres qui cadrent les paysages.
Ce sont les finitions.
C'est l'âme de cette maison
qui est devenue notre laboratoire
où nous testons comment utiliser des éléments standards
de manière non conventionnelle.
Nous constatons que le résultat est intriguant.
Nous apprenons en pratiquant
que la préfabrication peut être davantage que des boîtes empilées,
et que des structures lourdes peuvent être éthérées et transparentes.
Au-delà de la conception et de la construction de la maison,
les impressions que nous donnent nos familles et amis
sont une source d'apprentissage sans prix.
Car notre vie s'y déroule et notre travail en progression.
Les leçons que nous en retirons se traduisent dans d'autres projets,
d'autres programmes,
à d'autres échelles
et nous inspirent tous les jours.
Ici, nous avons des matériaux standards :
des ossatures en acier galvanisé que l'on peut aisément couper et tordre,
des mousses d'isolation, des plaques en ciment.
Tous ces matériaux qui sont toujours cachés dans les murs
et que nous exposons au grand jour.
Nous les utilisons pour développer un système de construction très léger
qui peut être assemblé par presque n'importe qui.
Nous les assemblons nous-mêmes, dans notre atelier.
Pourtant, nous sommes architectes, pas des professionnels de la construction.
Mais nous voulons nous assurer que c'est possible.
C'est génial qu'Antón puisse le porter seul,
que Javier puisse le poser dans un container,
et que nous puissions le livrer comme un déménagement à l'étranger.
C'est ce que nous avons fait il y a cinq ans.
Nous avons déplacé notre centre de gravité
et la maison faite de poutres en béton de Madrid à Brookline.
Nous avons trouvé le vilain petit canard d'un voisinage au demeurant très chic :
un garage d'un étage, le seul lieu que nous pouvions nous permettre.
Mais c'était idéal car nous nourrissions l'intention de le transformer en cygne.
On a déposé sur son toit notre kit de composants fraichement livrés
nous métamorphosant une fois de plus en scientifiques et en cobayes.
Cette maison utilise en fait les matériaux
les meilleurs marchés et les plus banals que l'on puisse trouver sur le marché
avec la modulation 4X8 omniprésente
dans l'industrie de la construction.
Toutefois, une organisation différente des espaces
et un assemblage différent des composants
permettent de transformer une maison construite de manière modeste
en un espace luxueux.
Aujourd'hui nous rêvons et nous travaillons avec des promoteurs,
des entreprises en construction, et des communautés
pour que ceci devienne la réalité pour davantage de maisons,
et un plus grand nombre de familles.
Voyez-vous, le monde qui nous entoure est une source d'inspiration infinie
si nous portons un regard curieux pour voir au-delà de la surface des choses.
Je vous emmène maintenant dans un autre coin de l'univers :
les paysages fastueux du Montana.
Il y a quelques années, nous y avons rejoint Cathy et Peter Halstead
pour imaginer le Tippet Rise Art Center dans les 4 000 hectares d'un ranch.
Dès notre première visite du site,
nous avons compris que tout ce que nous savions sur les centres artistiques
ne serait d'aucune utilité pour notre client,
pour la communauté et pour le paysage.
Un musée en forme de grande boîte blanche n'avait pas sa place là.
Nous avons choisi de fragmenter le centre en une constellation
d'espaces couvrant ce vaste territoire
afin d'immerger les visiteurs dans la beauté sauvage de ce lieu incroyable.
De retour au bureau, nous avons réfléchi
à utiliser le terrain comme fondation et comme matériau architectural,
apprenant de ses processus géologiques de sédimentation, d'érosion,
de fragmentation, de cristallisation,
ou d'explosion,
et nous permettant de découvrir des architectures nées de la terre,
issues des entrailles du paysage,
comme ce pont par exemple, qui enjambe le Canyon Murphy.
Ou cette fontaine.
Comme cet espace surmontant une colline,
ou ce théâtre qui nous projette dans l'espace des montagnes
et dans son univers sonore.
Pour concrétiser cette idée,
nous ne pouvions pas planifier parfaitement la construction.
Nous devons accepter le climat rigoureux et les méthodes locales.
Nous devons contrôler les aspects critiques
comme la structure, les propriétés thermiques et acoustiques
qui sont une part entière de la forme.
Hormis cela, nous accueillons et suscitons l'improvisation.
L'étape de la construction reste un moment de conception
et un moment de célébration
durant lequel diverses mains, cœurs et esprits s'unissent pour une danse ultime.
Le résultat n'est pas prévisible.
C'est une surprise.
Nous déballons l'architecture comme on déballerait un cadeau d'anniversaire.
L'architecture n'est pas dévoilée :
elle est découverte.
Elle est extraite des entrailles de la terre et devient un refuge,
répondant ainsi aux besoins les plus primitifs des hommes.
L'architecture, l'art, le paysage,
l'archéologie, la géologie deviennent un.
En utilisant de manière radicale les ressources disponibles,
en ménageant un espace pour l'expérience,
nous pouvons mettre à la lumière
des architectures qui dévoilent la beauté cachée
dans les éléments bruts et imparfaits qui nous entourent,
qui les élèvent
et leur permettent de parler leur langage.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)